if we walk ariana grande has broken her
silence on Mac Miller one week after his
death writing a heartfelt post on
Instagram that read I adored you from
the day I met you when I was 19 and I
always will I can't believe you aren't
here anymore
I really can't wrap my head around it we
talked about this so many times I'm so
mad I'm so sad I don't know what to do
you were my dearest friend for so long
above anything else I'm so sorry I
couldn't fix or take your pain away I
really wanted to the kindest sweetest
soul with demons he never deserved I
hope you're okay now rest I was just a
kid putting music on the Internet and
then of my fans kind of went crazy and
it wasn't until my fans were so
undeniable that people really started
you know focusing on who I was so I got
to thank my fans for everything because
you know if it wasn't for people to
support me I wouldn't do anything Mac
Miller died on September 7th at age 26
from an apparent overdose machan ariana
broke up in May grande addressed their
breakup on Twitter calling their
relationship toxic and claiming she
dealt with issues relating to Miller's
sobriety throughout their relationship
saying quote I am NOT a babysitter or a
mother and no woman should feel that
they need to be I have cared for him and
tried to support his sobriety and prayed
for his balance for years and always
will of course I'd rather be the corny
white rapper then the drug Dow mess who
can't even get out of his house
overdosing is just not cool
there's no legendary romance you don't
go down in history because you overdosed
Mac has been open about his struggles
with sobriety and depression over the
years like in this 2015 Larry King
interview I had a drug problem you know
for a long time it wasn't just in music
but I definitely was going through a
drug problem and they uh and and I think
it was more my state of mind I was
pretty depressed as everyone even while
successful yeah
Miller released his new album swimming
on August 3rd and was set to go on tour
starting in October just fourteen hours
prior to the news of his death he posted
a series of Instagram stories with music
from his new album
[Music]
[Music]